كما لو أن الناس يشاهدون العرض في الواقع لأنني كنت
مندهشًا جدًا ، مرحبًا
بكم في إصدار آخر من بين اثنين من السرخس ،
أنا مضيفك زاك جاليفياناكيس
وضيفي اليوم هو باراك أوباما ، رئيس
باراك أوباما ، من الجيد أن أكون معك. قرأت في
مكان ما أنك  أن تكون جالسًا ، هالك
هوجان إلى سوريا ، أو أن هذا العمل أكثر من ذلك
بالنسبة لتونيا هاردينغ زاك ، فهو ليس
سفيرنا ، فماذا يجب أن نفعل حيال شمال
ايكيا صحيحًا بينما ننتقل إليك ، تعرف ما إذا
كنت قد ركضت للمرة الثالثة وأكون نوعًا ما أشبه
بصداع مخلفات ثالث  الفيلم لم
ينجح حقًا جيدًا هل تعلم
ماذا سأفعل لو كنت رئيسًا للسيد.
رئيس ، سأجعل الطلاق من نفس الجنس
غير قانوني ، ثم أرى مدى سوء رغبتهم في ذلك ،
أعتقد أن هذا هو سبب عدم كونك
رئيسًا وهذا شيء جيد هل سمعت
عن قانون الرعاية بأسعار معقولة ، نعم
سمعت عن هذا الشيء الذي
لا يريده  لماذا ستحصل على الشخص
الذي أنشأ المنطقة لجعل
موقع الويب الخاص بك health.gov يعمل بشكل رائع
الآن ، الحقيقة هي أنه يمكنهم الحصول على
تغطية جميعًا مقابل تكلفة دفع
فاتورة هاتفك الخلوي ، وهذا ما
يقصدونه بالطائرات بدون طيار  النقطة المهمة هي أن الكثير
من الشباب يعتقدون أنهم
لا يقهرون ، هل قلت غير مرئي لأنه
لا يوجد لي هذا ليس غير
مرئي لا يقهر ، لا أريدك أيها
الناس تحب النظر إلى نصي إذا كنت
تعرف ما أعنيه أولاً
لا أحد يهتم بنصك ، لذا
أي بلد كنت تتجذر في
دورة الألعاب الأولمبية الشتوية بجدية ، أنا
رئيس الولايات المتحدة ، ما
رأيك أقول أريد أن أشكر الرئيس
أوباما لكونه في البرنامج سأضغط على
هذا أنا لا أفعل  ر تلمس هذا التنوير القائل
شكرا للمقابلة وشكرا
للسماح لي بتصوير عرضي هنا طوال هذه
السنوات التي كنت تصور فيها هذه
العروض هنا في الغرفة الدبلوماسية الذي
أعطاك الإذن للقيام بذلك على
محمل الجد الذي منحه تصريح ما هي
لدغة العنكبوت